>>> TONIGHT, DISTURBING VIDEO
SHOWING POLICE DRAGGING A BLACK
PARAPLEGIC MAN FROM HIS CAR
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP IN OHIO.
THAT MAN NOW ACCUSING THE DAYTON
POLICE DEPARTMENT OF RACIAL
PROFILING AND UNLAWFUL ARREST IN
A COMPLAINT WITH THE NAACP.
ATHENA JONES IS OUTFRONT.
>> THEY DRAGGED ME TO THE
VEHICLE LIKE A DOG, LIKE TRASH.
LIKE YOU TAKE OUT TRASH.
>> Reporter: THE VIDEO IS
DIFFICULT TO WATCH.
DAYTON, OHIO, POLICE PULLING A
BLACK PARAPLEGIC MAN FROM A CAR
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP LAST
MONTH.
>> I CAN'T STEP OUT OF THE CAR,
SIR.
I'M A PARAPLEGIC.
>> HELP YOU GETTING OUT.
I'M GOING TO HELP YOU GETTING
OUT.
I'M GOING TO HELP YOU GET OUT.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, SIR.
>> Reporter: 39-YEAR-OLD
CLIFFORD OWENSBY LAUNCHED A
COMPLAINT WITH THE NAACP.
HE ACCUSES POLICE OF PROFILING,
UNLAWFUL ARREST, ILLEGAL SEARCH
AND SEIZURE, AND FAILING TO READ
HIM HIS RIGHTS BEFORE TAKING HIM
TO JAIL.
POLICE SAY THEY STOPPED OWENS BY
AFTER SEEING HIM LEAVE A
SUSPECTED DRUG HOUSE.
AND BASED ON THAT SIGHTING AND
OWENSBY'S PAST HISTORY OF FELONY
DRUG AND WEAPONS CHARGES,
OFFICERS CALLED FOR A DRUG
SNIFFING DOG TO CHECK THE
VEHICLE.
DEPARTMENT POLICY REQUIRES
OCCUPANTS EXIT THE VEHICLE,
FIRST.
THE NEARLY 12 MINUTE POLICE
BODY-CAMERA VIDEO SHOWS AN
OFFICER PULLING OWENSBY OVER AND
ORDERING HIM OUT OF THE CAR.
>> I CANNOT STEP OUT OF THE CAR.
I CANNOT STEP OUT OF THE
VEHICLE.
>> YOU CAN GET OUT OF THE CAR.
>> Reporter: THE OFFICER SAYS
SEVERAL TIMES HE WILL HELP
OWENSBY OUT OF THE CAR.
OWENSBY DECLINES SAYING HE WILL
CALL SOMEONE HE KNOWS TO COME
HELP HIM.
>> HEY, BRO.
CAN YOU COME DOWN THE STREET
TO -- UM -- FERGUSON AND GRAND?
>> Reporter: THROUGHOUT THE
SEPTEMBER 30th INCIDENT, OWENSBY
REPEATEDLY ASKED THE OFFICER TO
CALL A SUPERIOR TO THE SCENE.
THE OFFICER SAYS HE WILL DO SO
BUT OWENSBY MUST GET OUT OF THE
CAR, FIRST.
>> YOU ARE GETTING OUT OF THE
CAR.
IT'S NOT AN OPTION.
YOU ARE GET OUT OF THIS CAR SO
YOU CAN COOPERATE AND GET OUT OF
THIS CAR OR I CAN DRAG YOU OUT
OF THE CAR.
>> SECONDS LATER, A STRUGGLE
ENSUES AS TWO OFFICERS FORCIBLY
REMOVE OWENSBY.
AT ONE POINT, PULLING HIM BY HIS
HAIR.
>> GET OUT OF THE CAR.
>> OW!
OW!
SOMEBODY, HELP!
>> Reporter: DAYTON POLICE MAJOR
BRIAN JOHNS SAID OFFICERS
RETRIEVED A BAG FROM OWENSBY'S
VEHICLE CONTAINING ABOUT $22,000
IN CASH.
OWENSBY SAID SUNDAY THE MONEY
WAS HIS SAVINGS, AND THAT NO
WEAPONS OR DRUGS WERE FOUND IN
THE SEARCH.
HE WAS NOT CHARGED WITH ANY
DRUG-RELATED OFFENSES.
A CHILD WAS ALSO IN THE CAR AT
THE TIME OF THE INCIDENT.
POLICE CITED OWENSBY FOR NOT
USING A CHILD RESTRAINT, AND FOR
HAVING TINTED GLASS WINDOWS THAT
OBSCURED VISION.
HE PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
DAYTON MAYOR NAN WEHLE TOLD THE
DAYTON DAILY NEWS A FULL
INVESTIGATION IS UNDERWAY, AND
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE OR WHAT
YOU LOOK LIKE, EVERYONE DESERVES
TO BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT WHEN DEALING WITH DAYTON
POLICE.
NOW, A SPOKESMAN FOR THE OHIO
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE SAYS
IT IS NOT INVESTIGATING THE
INCIDENT BECAUSE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR A COUNTY
PROSECUTOR MUST, FIRST, MAKE A
REFERRAL.
MEANWHILE, THE DAYTON FRATERNAL
ORDER OF POLICE TOLD THE DAYTON
DAILY NEWS, SOMETIMES THE
ARRESTS OF NONCOMPLIANT
INDIVIDUALS IS NOT PRETTY BUT IT
IS A NECESSARY PART OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL IDEOLOGIES OF OUR
SOCIETY.
THE OFFICERS INVOLVED ARE STILL
ON DUTY AS THE INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES.
ERIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, ATHENA, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> AND CLIFFORD OWENSBY IS NOW
OUTFRONT.
WITH HIM IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
DAYTON NAACP.
I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU TAKING
THE TIME TO -- TO TALK ABOUT
THIS OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY
DISTURBING TO WATCH THIS.
CLIFFORD, LET ME START WITH YOU.
CAN YOU TELL ME AND EVERYONE
WATCHING, IN YOUR OWN WORDS,
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU GOT
PULLED OVER?
>> UM, ONCE I GOT PULLED OVER,
UM, I WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION
THAT I WAS PULLED OVER FOR TINT.
SO I WAS EXPECTING FOR HIM TO
WRITE ME A TICKET AND THEN BE
LET GO SO I CAN CONTINUE ON
ABOUT MY DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME, I ENDED UP
WITH A BAD SCRATCH-OFF LOTTERY
TICKET, STRAIGHT TO JAIL.
>> SO, CLIFFORD, I -- I WANT TO
REPLAY.
YOU KNOW, IT -- IT -- IT'S HARD
FOR ANYONE TO WATCH THIS.
I -- I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES
YOU HAVE HAD TO REWATCH THIS,
YOURSELF.
BUT THE BODY-CAM VIDEO WHEN
OFFICERS DRAGGED YOU OUT OF THE
CAR.
AGAIN, FOR ANYONE WATCHING, I
WANT TO WARN PEOPLE IT'S
DIFFICULT BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED TO YOU.
HERE IS PART OF IT.
>> I'M A PARAPLEGIC, BRO.
YOU CAN HURT ME.
WHAT ARE Y'ALL DOING, BRO?
I'M A PARAPLEGIC, BRO.
I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU I GOT
HELP GETTING IN THE CAR.
THEY CAN HURT ME.
>> GET OUT OF THE CAR.
>> OW!
OW!
>> GET OUT OF THE CAR.
>> SOMEBODY HELP!
SOMEBODY, HELP!
>> CLIFFORD, WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH YOUR HEAD WHEN THIS
HAPPENED?
WHEN THEY PULLED YOU OUT OF THE
CAR?
>> I WAS IN FEAR OF MY LIFE.
UM, ALL I COULD DO IS JUST CLOSE
MY EYES AND GRAB THE STEERING
WHEEL AND -- AND -- AND I PRAYED
TO GOD IN MY HEAD TO, YOU KNOW,
MAKE SURE THAT IT DIDN'T GO THE
WAY THAT IT WENT.
AND THEY SNATCHED ME OUT OF THE
VEHICLE BY MY HAIR, AND I DON'T
KNOW.
IT JUST -- IT'S A CONSTANT
REMINDER, EVERY DAY, YOU KNOW,
AND I -- I CAN'T GET PAST THE
FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
HUMILIATED LIKE THAT AND THEY
WOULD DO ANYONE LIKE THAT.
TREAT ANY CITIZENS OF DAYTON,
OHIO, OR ANYWHERE ELSE LIKE
THAT.
>> AND -- AND I KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT THE HUMILIATION THAT YOU
FELT.
I MEAN, DEREK, WITH EVERYTHING
THAT CLIFFORD IS SAYING AND WITH
THE CONTEXT THAT ATHENA HAD IN
HER PIECE HERE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED, ARE YOU CONVINCED
THIS WAS RACIAL PROFILING?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SAY THAT IT'S
RACIAL PROFILING BECAUSE THE
GENTLEMAN WHO ACTUALLY PULLED
HIM OUT OF THE CAR WAS
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
WHAT THIS WAS WAS A PRETEXTUAL
STOP THAT LED TO AN EGREGIOUS
ACT ON A CITIZEN WITHIN THESE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
BY WAYS OF CLIFFORD OWENSBY, OUR
CLIENT.
SO THE WAY THAT WE VIEW THIS IS
THE OFFICERS -- THE OFFICER WAS
VERY AGGRESSIVE FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND AS OWENSBY STATED, THAT'S
WHY HE WAS FEARFUL OF HIS LIFE
WHEN THE OFFICER ASKED HIM TO
GET OUT OF THE CAR.
NUMBER ONE, YOU HEARD THE
OFFICER STATE VERY CLEARLY
INSIDE THE VIDEO THAT YOU GOT
ONE OR TWO THINGS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
NUMBER ONE, EITHER YOU ARE GOING
TO GET OUT OF THE CAR.
OR NUMBER TWO, WE'RE GOING TO
DRAG YOU OUT OF THE CAR.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO OFFICER CHOSE THE LATTER.
THE OFFICER CHOSE TO DRAG HIM
OUT OF THE CAR BECAUSE, NUMBER
ONE -- YOU KNOW, WAS NOT GOING
TO TAKE PLACE BECAUSE HE COULD
NOT GET OUT OF THE CAR ON HIS
OWN.
SO THE OFFICER'S ACTIONS, IN OUR
VIEW, WERE EGREGIOUS.
HE WAS UPSET FOR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY HAVE BEEN.
BUT THIS SHOULD -- A -- A
TRAFFIC STOP -- A PRETEXTUAL
TRAFFIC STOP WITH A -- REGARDING
THE TINT ON HIS WINDOWS SHOULD
NOT HAVE LED TO A CITIZEN WITHIN
THESE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
IN THE 21st CENTURY TO BE
DRAGGED IN THEIR CAR LIKE AN
ANIMAL WITH HIS HAIR DRUG ACROSS
THIS PARKING LOT.
AND FURTHERMORE, AS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT HIM GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL, YOU KNOW, OR NOT EVEN
THE HOSPITAL.
EVEN GETTING INSIDE OF THE
POLICE CRUISER.
OUR CLIENT -- THEY WOULD NOT
EVEN ASSIST OUR CLIENT TO GET IN
THE POLICE CRUISER IN A -- IN A
HUMANE WAY.
THEN, EVEN GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL.
THE SAME WAY.
IN TERMS OF HIM BEING ABLE TO
GET OUT AND BEING TAKEN CARE OF
AT THE HOSPITAL.
AND THEN, SO MUCH SO THAT WHEN
THEY ACTUALLY TOOK HIM BACK
TO -- TOOK HIM TO JAIL FROM THE
HOSPITAL, THE INTAKE REFUSED TO
EVEN ACCEPT HIM.
SO, WHEN THE -- WHEN THE INTAKE
REFUSED TO ACCEPT HIM AT THE
JAIL, THEN AFTER THAT POINT IN
TIME, HE HAD TO -- HE ASKED THE
OFFICERS TO TAKE HIM BACK TO
WHERE THEY FOUND HIM BECAUSE THE
OFFICERS ASKED HIM, WELL, WHERE
DO -- WHERE DO YOU WANT US TO
TAKE YOU?
AND THE OFFICER SAID HE SAID CAN
YOU TAKE ME BACK TO WHERE YOU
PICKED ME UP?
THE OFFICER DID NOT DO THAT.
AND ULTIMATELY, HE HAD TO CALL A
RIDE TO COME PICK HIM UP FROM
THE JAIL.
YOU KNOW, SO THE -- THE -- THE
SITUATION WAS CLEARLY
UNNECESSARY.
THE OFFICER SHOULD HAVE BEEN PUT
ON DESK DUTY.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PUT -- SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PUT ON ADMINISTRATIVE
LEAVE IMMEDIATELY.
>> YES.
>> UNTIL A FULL INVESTIGATION
ENSUED.
>> SO, CLIFFORD, LET ME ASK YOU
AND -- AND IT IS -- YOU KNOW, AS
YOU EMPHASIZE, THEY ARE STILL
BACK ON DUTY AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT.
RIGHT?
THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO MOVE TO
DESK DUTY AT THIS POINT OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
UM, YOU KNOW, CLIFFORD, YOU TALK
ABOUT THINKING YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
PULLED OVER FOR TINTED WINDOWS.
THE POLICE SAY THEY STOPPED YOU
BECAUSE YOU WERE LEAVING A
SUSPECTED DRUG HOUSE AND THAT
BECAUSE OF YOUR FELONY DRUG
HISTORY AND WEAPON HISTORY,
THAT'S WHY THEY REQUESTED A
NARCOTICS K-9 AT THE SCENE.
AND THEN, THE K-9 REACTED TO
YOUR $22,000 IN CASH SUGGESTING
IT WAS NEAR ILLEGAL DRUGS.
OBVIOUSLY, I KNOW THEY DID NOT
FIND ANY IN YOUR CAR AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY TO ALL THAT?
THEY'RE GIVING THIS -- THIS
INVOLVED DESCRIPTION.
>> SEEMED LIKE I'VE BEEN
PROFILED.
AGAIN, THERE WERE NO DRUGS,
WEAPONS, OR ANYTHING FOUND.
THEY JUST -- I DON'T KNOW --
I'M -- I'M NOT SURE WHAT THEIR
INTENTIONS WERE.
BUT THEY DEFINITELY HURT ME AND
I -- I BEEN IN PAIN EVER SINCE.
HAVING TO WATCH THAT VIDEO OVER
AND OVER.
IT JUST -- I CAN'T GET PAST IT.
>> AND WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SITUATION, WHETHER OR NOT IT
WAS A KNOWN DRUG HOUSE OR NOT,
IT'S HIS PROPERTY.
HE IS A BUSINESSMAN INSIDE OF
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
HE OWNS SEVERAL PROPERTIES.
HE WENT OVER THERE -- HE WENT
OVER THERE TO GET SOME -- SOME
CABLE BOXES FROM THE PROPERTY.
SO HE TOOK THOSE CABLE BOXES
WERE IN HIS CAR AND AS HE
PROCEEDED TO TAKE OFF, THEN THE
OFFICER STOPPED HIM SHORTLY
THEREAFTER.
SO EVERYTHING INSIDE OF HIS
STORY IS VERY CLEAR.
HE WENT THERE FOR A PARTICULAR
PURPOSE.
>> YES.
>> HE LEFT.
HE LEFT THERE AND THE OFFICERS
DECIDED TO STOP HIM WITH A
PRETEXTUAL STOP.
SO IT HAD NOTHING TO DO -- THEY
WERE HOPING TO FIND DRUGS.
THEY WERE HOPING TO FIND
WEAPONS.
SOMETHING ILLEGAL TO CHARGE HIM
WITH.
BUT -- BUT IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE, THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
WE CANNOT CHANGE -- THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT CANNOT CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
THIS PARTICULAR STOP.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY, WAS
OBVIOUSLY -- IT WAS OBVIOUSLY
INCREDIBLY HARD TO WATCH.
AN